J'aime toujours décrire métaphoriquement
notre enfance comme lui étant le
propriétaire foncier et nous les gens qui travaillons sur
la terre,
mes parents ne nous ont pas encouragés à
communiquer avec la société, donc vous étiez un
peu fermé en
soulevant toujours cet appartement en
été, il y avait plus  une chance que
nous sortions parfois nous sortons une fois par
an c'est comme 3d man c'est très
frais ici et à une année particulière nous
ne sommes jamais sortis du tout
alors les films ont ouvert un autre monde je
n'avais pas de films la vie serait jolie
ennuyeux cette tenue est faite de boîtes de céréales
et de tapis de yoga nous ne nous sommes pas fait d'
amis nous étions scolarisés à la maison
Je vis en
quelque sorte parce que c'est un peu magique Je
me souviens avoir eu très peur de sortir
dans le monde Il pense que
quelqu'un nous suit Je suis sûr que
quelqu'un suit
mon père Son système était comme une
bombe à retardement À quoi s'attendait-il  quand
nous deviendrons tous majeurs, nous ferons les
choses à sa manière
Je ne pense pas que notre père savait que nous l'avions
en nous
Je suppose qu'ici nous nous voyions comme les petits
garçons qui ne pouvaient pas
et puis nous nous sommes transformés en garçons
qui peut